Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome to Resident Evil 7.
*beep*
*banging noises* *muffled talking* I'm not home. I'M NOT HOME!
Oh fuck. Oh fuck!
I'M A BRAVE BOY!
*beep*
I got stabbed in the shoulder, and stabbed through my fucking HAAAAAAND!
*juicy sounds of juiciness* Huh, yeah. That'll fix it up.
PBBBTBT!! Oh, yeah, let me get some goop juice on that!
*beep*
*Mark professionally opens a door* AAH!
Fucking goddammit! Did he see me? Did he hear me shout?
He probably did.
*beep*
And now that I've got that, I can go around the back way.
Marguerite: STAY THE FUCK-- Mark: Oh! Marguerite: OUT!
Oh. Nice ventriloquist act!
I think-- AAH!
*beep*
What am I gonna do about this? I got Goop Juice. HUH-PPBBTVBT!
Yeah! That felt guuuud!
*beep*
Hello. Eek! Hi. I shouldn't pick that up. I'm now cursed forev--
OHOHOHOHOHOHOHO
*Mark groaning*
Oh, No.
*beep*
Is it time for Goop Juice? I don't know if Goop Juice can fix this.
Better try real bad. IT'S A BIG ONE! *giggity*
HUH-PSFSDHJDVJHBSDFHGSJDFVSFD
♪REMIX | Back That A$$ Up♪